[Music]
good afternoon welcome to accessible
audio Android hearing aid support and
the audio framework my name is Brian
Kemmler and I'm a p.m. on the Android
accessibility team our team's mission is
to improve the lives of people with
disabilities by creating useful and
innovative products specifically we
design Android accessibility suite sound
amplifier live transcribe and as you may
have heard today now live caption the
last year and a half we've invested
heavily in making audio on Android more
accessible and so we're going to be
focusing on that in this talk I'm here
today with an awesome cast of characters
our engineers and product managers
Ricardo John and Stanley so we are going
to talk not only about what we've done
but about what you can do with the work
that we've created by leveraging the
Android audio framework first I'm gonna
walk you guys through hearing loss
literally and figuratively so we're
gonna talk all about it to help you
build empathy and actually hear or
experience what that is like
next Ricardo is going to go under the
hood and talk about the technologies
we've baked in to the platform so you
can make your apps and your devices more
accessible and have a better experience
for your users
lastly john and stanley are going to get
up and talk about hearing aid support
and how to create the best experience
possible whether you're a device maker
or an OEM now let's get started
so first let's walk through and talk
about what hearing loss is how it
affects people and what we can do about
it so the scope of the problem is
massive 466
million people worldwide have hearing
loss if that were a country that would
be a bigger country than every country
except for India and China
so that's bigger than the u.s. so this
is a massive problem and again according
to the World Health Organization this is
actually supposed to grow to nearly a
billion people in the year 2050 five so
can have a dramatic effect not only in
the people who have it but also their
friends families colleagues and loved
ones these effects can include fatigue
social isolation or reduced job or
academic performance now in my own life
both my dad in this picture and my best
friend from university had hearing loss
and its really made communicating with
them on difficult and challenging and
not only for them but also and also for
me so what is hearing loss how do we
quantify or measure it so this is an
empty audiogram and we're gonna walk you
through this on the top we have the
normal range of hearing at the very
bottom we have profound loss and then we
have different gradations in between on
the Left we have loud sounds at the
bottom and at the bottom we have
frequency measured in pitch measured in
Hertz from low to high going left left
to right this line is called the
threshold of hearing anything above it
you cannot hear unless you're a dog or a
dolphin in which case dogs actually hear
three times better than humans and
dolphins hear way better something like
seven times better than humans which is
absolutely amazing
now I'm overlaying the regions in which
music and speech occur so we have a
music region a speech region and
anything outside of these two regions is
in that is in that threshold what we
can't what we can't hear people with
loss in the speech region may have
difficulty interpreting speech and
similarly if you have law
in the music region you'll have
difficulty interpreting music so now
let's focus a little bit on speech on
the left hand side we have low frequency
sounds so these would typically be women
or I'm sorry men's voices so think think
baritones on the right hand side we have
high frequency loss so this would
typically be women's voices children's
voices think Sopranos this is called the
speech banana and I didn't make this up
this is like actually a thing so this is
where we hear consonants and vowels and
so you can see this little overlay where
all of these where all these letters
literally sit for English persons with
mild high frequency loss will have
difficulty hearing f th and s so in
other words a sentence like this is your
fate could become something completely
unintelligible to anybody like EE you're
8 what does that mean nothing so that's
how you can experience hearing loss and
let's shift from speech over to sound so
in this overlay I'm overlaying typical
sounds and where they where they take
place so you can see we have very loud
sounds like the lawnmower the phone the
bus at the very bottom and quieter ones
like the wind and the seagull at the top
this is an all the audiogram for a
fictitious patient and so we stripped
away the sounds of consonants the vowels
and so forth and we can measure the
ability to hear for each ear left and
right and so the right ear is read and
the left ear is blue
loss will vary by person and indeed it's
going to vary ear to ear and over time
this will this will change so you can
see the pattern of gloss in this example
is high frequency loss and that is one
of the most typical forms of hearing
loss now we're laying everything on top
so we have the sounds we
the audiogram and basically everything
down into the left is going to be
audible for this person everything up
and to the right is going to be
inaudible so they can hear the bus the
baby on the phone but they cannot hear
the the seagull or the clock and the
wind so a hearing aid this is a very
simplified example but a hearing aid is
going to work by injecting the right
amount of game so turning up turning up
the volume and the right amount of
signal processing at the appropriate
freaking at the appropriate frequency
levels it also works by lowering the
gain so that you're not overloading the
ears insert in certain cases so this can
make up for loss and this is called
compensation and the amount of
compensation again it's going to vary
from individual to individual to
individual and I'm sort of showing this
fictitiously by raising up this raising
up this line so hearing these are really
really really effective they work they
work well but they're not perfect
solutions according to a recent survey
the majority of respondents said that
their quality of life was improved with
the hearing aid compared to no
amplification at all so that's really
really good but there are a lot of
challenges with hearing aids too so for
people who self-identified as having
difficulty hearing that was about 10% of
population however only a corresponding
3% of the population
reported having one or more hearing aid
devices so there are a lot of reasons
why hearing aids are not widely adopted
one is expensed typically they're not
covered by insurance too sadly there
could be a stigma associated with
wearing a hearing aid or people just
don't want to admit that they have that
they have that have this loss so we're
doing a bunch of things about this but
what I want to do right now is a hearing
loss simulation demo so I'm gonna switch
over and run this demo for you guys
playing some music so you guys get a
sense of what normal hearing is like and
then what
hearing with hearing loss sounds like
Tim oh so I'm gonna play play a little
opera for you guys so right now using
our hearing loss simulator I basically
in a very simplistic sense turn the
volume down
even though even though the audio was
still playing now what I'm going to
demonstrate using our sound amplifier
product is how we can apply some basic
compensation to this loss and you can
get to experience the effect of the
product so I'm going to play the music
again and then I'm going to switch over
to sound amplifier so again you can
barely hear it but the music is actually
playing now I'm going to turn on sound
amplifier
[Music]
honey supplying some of the pie what's
that
okay enabled son I'm fine
the demo gods are not with us okay they
are now there we go thank you
but this is why as a product manager you
always need to have an engineer by your
side so right now I'm playing with the
boost
[Music]
and a user would simply use this by
finding the right combination of the
settings kill them Mozart and we can
produce the sound with a sound amplifier
[Music]
there we go thank you
back to the slides please so sound
amplifier is not a hearing aid but we do
use machine learning to process audio in
real time
in order to make listing a little easier
it'll add gain in quiet situations and
it will also help reduce distracting
background noise sound amplifier is free
and you need nothing more than a set of
wired head headphones to boost the sound
of a faraway speaker a TV the movie or
reduce the noise of an annoying heating
ventilation and air-conditioning system
sound amplifier dramatically lowers the
barriers to entry for somebody who can't
afford doesn't have or forgets the
batteries to their hearing aids so that
now that we've understood a little bit
more about hearing loss Ricardo's going
to discuss how you can use some of the
technology under the hood of sound
amplifier to make your products more
accessible for everybody
Ricardo Thank You Bryan
some a hello I'm Ricardo Garcia I'm a
software engineer in the Android audio
frankerz team and I'm also the tech lead
for the son of the fire project that you
just saw so today in this segment we are
going to talk more about how to build
sound enhancement in your own
applications so the question is when
would you like sound enhancement there
are many many situations where your
applications can benefit from this one
example is the one that we just saw that
when you have a sound amplification
application you would like to take a
microphone input and process the sound
and somehow enhance that sound bring
some soft sounds up a take some very
loud sounds and put them down something
that you would like to process in that
way sometimes also let's say that you
are building your own Android
device a speaker or something that has a
headphone and you would like to tune how
that speaker that headphone sounds you
would like to voice that speaker and
make it have a certain frequency profile
another application will be let's say
that you're building an Android TV and
you would like to implement the TV
midnight mode you are watching a movie
at home at midnight and you know
watching the movie and you have very
loud sounds and explosions but you also
have someone whispering right there you
would like to have some dynamics
processing that is going to bring up the
very soft sounds and it's going to bring
down the very loud sounds so everything
sounds better and your partners at home
would not kick you out of home or if you
want to have a media player application
and you would like to level the loudness
from song to song from toy from video to
video you can build a these kind of
applications and you can use a sound
enhancement to make the experience
better for your users so in this section
we are going to have three major things
the first one is a little reminder of
what we have about ADA dynamics
processing effect the DP that we
introduced last year we are going also
to a beam show the code of an equalizer
ana
app a simple application just doing an
equalization and we are going to have a
look inside of our very own sound
amplifier especially how we control the
parameters how we do the noise reduction
and the goal is that with all these
tools you could actually go out and
build your own stand on two files and
this you then to your users so to start
with the refresher the dynamics
processing effect DP for sure because
I'm going to say that many times today
the dynamics process effect was
introduced in Android Pi last year and
we also had a talk in Google i/o which
has a little bit more a a content at
this one but it's a good reference to
have with the dynamics process in fact
we have a very flexible architecture
that would allow developers to implement
dynamic processing effects in the way
that you want to implement them a for
example we have we process the sound by
channels you have left and right you
will have two channels in there so we
are going to do some processing
on each one of the channels and in the
channels we have four blocks four
modules where that can be used for sound
processing we have a pretty Q an
equalizer that can shape the frequency
response of the sound we have a
multiband compressor that allows for
different frequencies to treat the sound
in different ways a compressor does one
of the things that I mentioned before
that it takes very loud sounds and make
them softer and very soft sounds and
make them louder which is the heart of
the Sun amplifier that we saw post
equalizer also to be able to shape this
the spectrum of the sound that is coming
out and we have a limiter a limiter is a
very good safety device that a after you
have done all this processing if you
have for some reason a pop or so a very
loud sound is good to have a limiter
that is going to limit how loud that
sound is going to go when it's coming
out of the processing and inside of each
one of these modules we have a lot of
parameters a lot of bands that we can
control individually and in addition to
that we have many channels so as you see
our architecture would allow us to
actually have a lot of channels a lot of
stages and a lot of parameters in each
one of them which is kind of difficult
to control but it gives you a lot of
power to port your ogron's into this
pattern going into code I want to show
how this system is instantiated first we
introduce our dynamics processing effect
we import the dynamics processing effect
module in your java a code then do we
create a we are using the Builder design
pattern where we are going to configure
what we want the dynamics processing
effect to do and then we actually create
the dynamics processing effect in this
case we are saying that we want to
favour frequency resolution instead of
time domain we have different flavors of
processing with frequency domain you can
have more control of how your
frequencies are distributed in the
frequency domain with time resolution
with time favoring time resolution you
will have more control of how big your
blocks in time will be so if you want
fast response probably you would like to
have the time domain implementation we
can also say how many channels we want
and in then we
we can say in this stages if we want to
use pre q and how many bands in this
case we want to use pre q and 12 bands
we want to use pausing a multiband
compressor and eight bands and we want
to use pasta q 16 bands and also the
limiter so pretty much we are using
everything that we have a access to then
we can set some a parameters that are
preferred we are kind of hinting the
system we would like to have frames that
are 10 milliseconds long doesn't mean
that the system is going to comply but
is going to do the best effort to offer
us 18 milliseconds frames we can ask for
something smaller something something
longer
it depends what your algorithm needs
then we create the config object and we
are ready to go to the next stage in the
next stage we haven't created the
dynamics processing effect yet we would
like to go and a get whole of the
multiband compressor and change some of
the default parameters so we get a hold
of that and we are going to iterate in
this moment in the 8 bands in this toy
example that I have here we get a hold
of the band we get in this moment we set
some of the parameters like the attack
time to be 50 milliseconds we set the
release time to be a hundred
milliseconds we can set all the other
parameters whatever that we want there
and this can really mimic the algorithm
is that we already have in place or they
are the specs that your sound designers
or your son engineers require for your
application and finally we are going to
create the dynamics processing effect
the one that I call my DP that one is my
actual a dynamics processing that is
going to do all the signal processing a
very important part is that we have the
session ID and this is something that as
a developers is going to give you the
flexibility to create a media player or
to start playing a sound and then create
an effect and put them together because
you are using the same session ID and we
are going to see that in the next
example
so to recap we are creating the dynamic
processing effect and we have access to
a lot of parameters that we can control
either at the need time or at runtime at
runtime we can go and change what is the
frequency that we want to do
to affect how much energy we wanna miss
frequency we can control everything
real-time and in this graph we see that
we have channels inside of the channels
we have different stages pre cue
multiband compressor post EQ and the
limiter and inside of each one of them
we have bands and multiples parameters
that we can control so a one very quick
example I'm going to use this equaliser
demo and I'm going to show you the code
that I use for this application so can
we switch to the demo please so I have a
very simple application that is called
equalizer I'm going to play so I'm not
doing any hearing loss I'm just wanting
to play here and I'm going to start
modifying the bands in there so
[Music]
okay that was the demo so I just wanted
to show that he's running and I'm going
to show you how is working so back to
the slide please
so we start with we create a media
player we go to the code and we just use
the same code that we have used for many
years to create a media object in this
case is the media player and I'm playing
a classical music it's an example in
there but the most important thing is
that when I create that we have this
session i did as i mentioned before we
create a media player and we are you
going to use this session ID in a second
when we create the dynamics processing
effect so I'm going to go inside my
function that is there the last one
called create VP that is my own custom
function I'm using the Builder a design
pattern that I'm going to say how many
channels I want how how many bands I
want I'm just going to use the first one
that is the EQ and a I'm going to create
a in the each one of the EQ bands what
is the level the initial level so I know
that is a lot of code there but the most
important part is that when we have
created this and at runtime when I'm
moving the sliders what I'm doing when I
move in sliders if you're looking here
the section that I just highlighted
there every time that I move one of the
sliders I go and find the band of
interest for that EQ and just assign a
different value there I say I want to
attenuate or I want to enhance that band
this is all this is all the code that
you need to run a very powerful very
configurable EQ in your application and
now I'm going to go to my last part of
my my talk I know that is a lot of data
but a inside of the Sun amplifier so our
Sun amplifier at the application that
Brian a demo before he is built on top
of the dynamics processing effect we are
using the line sources effect that
anyone that is using under a pipe or or
above a can have access to and it has in
the architecture it has two parts that I
want to make emphasis
two the first one is the control part
the top part very much the user has
access to the UI it can move some
sliders and when it moves the sliders
the application is computing some
parameters that get sent to the dynamics
processing effect there it says change
the EQ here change this band here move
things here this is all done in the UI I
will say in the control part but all the
number crunching all day the magic is
happening in the dynamics processing
effect that belongs to the OS another
part that I want to show is a day audio
part we are doing some noise reduction
analysis in the audio but at the end we
are just selecting some parameters that
will get sent to the dynamics processing
effect to tell the system how to process
the audio how do we do this the first
part the UI part so our problem is we
have two sliders and we will like the
dynamics processing effect to change the
parameters that discuss what type of
changes we want on those parameters we
are going to use some EQ and compression
we are going to do what Brian show us to
do that hearing aids do that they just
changed some of the parameters how they
affect the frequency response and how
they affect the frequency in different
frequencies in different ways we can go
and in this case the top curve is
telling me to boost some of the low
frequencies and they the bottom curve is
telling me to apply some compression
also to the low frequencies but still
that's a lot of parameters for a user to
control directly we could simplify these
curves by just saying well you know
let's say let's take this lobe of the
curve I'm just to represent the whole
curve with all these parameters with a
single number and if I do that for both
curves I could plot that in a
two-dimensional space I could say the
first curve is one number the second
curve is another number I have an XY
coordinate and I just represent that in
that space as the circle that you see
there I could do the same for another
curve and it's a different point that I
get in XY coordinate the same for
another curve another curve so we can
get a lot of curves that get represented
even though that they have a lot of
parameters that get represented in the
XY coordinate very simple
the magic at the beauty of this is that
now with an XY coordinate to a map we
can just take our boost and our
fine-tuning and we could pretty much
navigate that XY coordinate space very
easy go and find what is the point that
is closest to what the user wants and
that gets translated to a lot of
parameters that gets sent to the
dynamics processing effect so we're
actually doing multi-dimensional mapping
we are taking something that has many
dimensions and reducing that to two
dimensions okay of course this is a toy
example there is a lot of math involved
in there but the idea that you get the
idea but one of the other important
things that we did here is that we took
many curves from many people from many
audiograms and with those audiograms we
managed to a count with all these curves
that represent the kind of hearing
enhancement that a lot of people will
benefit from in the real world in the
when they're in a coffee shop and a
restaurant on different places okay and
to finish I want to talk a little bit
about noise reduction with noise
reduction what we do is in the bottom
part we are get hold of the audio we are
looking at the audio that is coming
through the microphone but we would like
to get rid of sounds that especially
they are all there like there for the
for a long time for example that AC
sound that is reading and annoying so if
we start looking at the spectrum of the
sound and we take and one spectrum
within another a spectrum that another
spectrum we can see what is pretty much
there for a long period of time versus
something that changes a lot like my
voice that is just there for a second
and there is not there the next instance
when we compute that we can go and tell
the DP you know these frequencies that
have been there for a long time please
put them down and an attenuator now just
to recap we look inside the dynamics
process in FA we build our own equalizer
and we talk about the sound amplifier
noise reduction and the control UI now
we are going to go to John and Stanley
to know more about a Android a hearing
aid support thank you
thanks Ricardo let's talk about hearing
aids so first I'm gonna go over what the
existing landscape looks like and where
what we've built in fits in and then I'm
gonna hand it off to Stanley who's gonna
talk through exactly how to build this
into your devices if you're an OEM or a
hearing aid maker so today if you want
to get audio from your Android phone to
your hearing aids it's not so easy
typically you'll need what's called a
streamer and this is a small piece of
hardware that you wear on your body that
allows the phone to relay an audio
signal to the hearing aids and the
reason why this exists is because of
battery life so Bluetooth classic
is just not good enough for the power
constraints of a hearing aid device and
we can't ask hearing aid users to
replace the battery on the order of
hours or days and so what the streamer
does is it will take a classic Bluetooth
signal from the phone to the streamer
and then use a proprietary low power
link to send the audio to the hearing
aids but this introduces two problems
the first is that it's just simply
something else to worry about if you
lose it or damage it you're out of luck
and the second is it's another thing to
keep charged we have a growing ecosystem
of devices all of us have smartwatches
smartphones tablets and more and to have
yet another thing you need to plug in
every night or every other night is a
pain because if you wake up and it's not
charged you're out of luck so we
challenged ourselves to do better and we
worked really hard these past few months
we think we really have so you'll be
able to take calls stream music all
without an accessory because we built
direct streaming support for hearing
aids right into Android well we didn't
stop there we really listened to users
and we know that battery life is
incredibly important and so what we've
actually done is challenged ourselves to
build battery life into the hearing aids
that's better than a regular headphone
and the team delivered we've been able
to deliver week-long battery life even
with streaming support this isn't
something that any headphone can do so
how do we do it well Bluetooth classic
wasn't enough so we had to go to
something else and we turned to
bluetooth low energy or ble for short
to get audio from the phone to the
hearing aids what we do is we actually
open up two audio channels called
low-energy connection-oriented channels
where we send the data we have one
channel per hearing aid device and the
benefit of using ble over classic is
that all the power savings we get we can
push back to the user as battery life so
there's no need to recharge your hearing
aids every single night in addition all
of the important ways in which you
interface with your hain aids are built
directly into Android which means right
out of the box you'll be able to pair
connect and stream so there's no need
for a third party app we do really love
third-party apps though because they
allow you to enhance your listening
experience you can customise EQ and
adjust your hearing profile based on
where you are whether you're in a
restaurant whether you're outside or in
a presentation like this and so they're
not going away
in fact we've actually created some new
API switch Stanley is going to talk
through to make your life easier and to
make hearing aid companies to enable
them to build really killer apps so
we'll be launching with support for
select GN hearing aids and cochlear
implant Able's and we're really excited
about these partnerships we worked super
hard with these companies over the past
few months to build some killer products
that we think users are going to love
but we're also excited for all of the
other hearing aid companies that are in
the pipeline so keep your eyes out for
other people and companies who will be
showing up here within the next few
months so phone calls audio music
podcasts and more all without an
accessory and all with a week of battery
life this has been an amazing effort and
partnership and we're super excited
about what this is going to do for the
466 million people who have disabling
hearing loss I'm gonna hand it over to
Stanley now who's going to talk through
exactly how to build this into your
device if you're an om thank you
[Applause]
thanks John I'm Stan little from the
Android Bluetooth team I'll be talking
through how Android devices can support
young it directly so the very first
thing is that go and look at our open
and publicly available enjoy hearing aid
specifications in a given link here once
your read aspect you want to make sure
that the Android device that you undo of
point can support are sure I'll be going
through the list of requirements a bit
later then reach out photo Google to
receive reference hearing aid devices
for your testing our development is done
with open source and on the AOSP code
base so with your reference devices and
the AOSP open source code you have
everything you need to build a solution
but my stress is very important in you
test thoroughly with the reference
device to make sure it's correct our
test plan will be made available for you
shortly to test for both quality and
interoperability so let's talk about
what are the Android platform
requirements very good news there is no
new hardware or Bluetooth chip firmware
needed to support our show you you just
use any be DC compliant Bluetooth
chipsets we didn't want to define any
new vendor specific API commands that
means you could still use your the
generic Bluetooth firmware that there's
product from your chip provider however
we do prefer a BT 500 chipset as John
has mentioned we are using the OE
connection on the channels or COC
for short you want to make sure that
your implementation of COC is good on
your Android platform
therefore please spend the falling
tutors the CTS verifier and the a CTS
tests we have written special case on
COC for you now
do approach your Bluetooth chip vendor
and make sure they on these two
parameters they are called admin C
parameter and maxie parameters so these
two parameters are used whenever the
connection parameters are updated so
it's important they honored it so that
you have good quality audio lastly for
your audio home module please make sure
you implement this to new audio routes
that is needed for hearing aids that's
it no I said no new hardware now if you
are hearing makers the following slides
have useful information on how to be a
Asha compatible device firstly go read
our open and publicly available our
suspect you are supposed to there since
last August to start building you need
to obtain a pixel tree phone running
queue since pixel 3 will be the first
phone to support a sure as I've said
before our implementation is open source
and in the AOSP source code please look
at our SP to see how we implement the
audio source and this should help you to
implement your audio sync we have Bill
new api's in android q to make your life
easier remember to use these api's when
running your app how tom over this api
is in a bit
finally a must rest
test thoroughly
we'll be releasing our test plans and we
also be compiling common issues and
showing them as a FAQ to make life
easier let's trouble the new API so for
Android Q we are define a new Bluetooth
profile Cody here is profile so this
with this new profile your app can
detect whether the phone has hearing
support or not this new API allows your
app to install manage configure the pair
devices
furthermore the apps can still continue
used to use their existing early
services on your hearing aids this means
that all the special features and
enhancements that's available on your
hereness is still have is still possible
with your app just a small code segment
to demonstrate how a phone how you could
check whether phone supports the hearing
profile we have defined you profile ID
and you can imagine using this and your
app level to verify that the phone is
compatible and if not through a
notification to the user I like to cover
a few more things to watch out for
because the Android device is streaming
audio to two different hearing devices
on two separate channels there's a need
to synchronize the two audio stream
hearing devices must have their own
stereo sync method however on the
Android side we will assist by summing
the triggers to the device whenever this
thing need to happen stay tuned and
check the our suspect because we are
adding more details than we are using
the early connection other channels
especially the credit based flow control
so this credit is controlled by the hero
devices to let and drug knows when to
sign the next audio data therefore this
flow control is important mechanism to
regulate the amount of data that the
Android device sent to the hearing aids
as I study for pics at 3 & 3 so 3 Excel
will be the first devices to support
Asha if you are keen on building quickly
go grab one to start development thank
you let me hurt him back to Brian Thank
You Stanley
so this feature I think is one of the
most important features that we're
launching because it means users are
gonna have like the best possible
experience on Android with hearing aids
a stream music stream anything and
Stanley was really the prime mover
technically behind this a big shout out
to sailing for making that happen
so we talked today about hearing loss
and help you understand it a little bit
better and then Ricardo dived in and
helped you understand how to build your
own equalizer and effects into into your
software in your hardware and that was
awesome
we're running out of time so if you guys
are interested we have another talk
tomorrow to mystifying Android
accessibility development which is a
very developer focused talk tomorrow at
9:30 a.m. on stage 7 and we also have
two really cool sandboxes the
accessibility sandbox and the experiment
sandbox which should be right out there
so I hope everybody had a chance to
learn something new and I hope you all
have a great eye oh thank you so much
for coming out and hope to see you
around or next year
[Music]